what about fruit fruity kind of dessert
that's the best dessert I just think
that fruit is always [__]
um
how did we we're just oh [__] I'm just
saying it right he couldn't have said
like a more perfectly opposite yeah I
think that vegetables Trump fruits in
every single way well yeah and I don't
want I don't want I have no time no but
like you know in a meal right that makes
sense but like what about in a dessert
I'd just rather not I just have
something like like an ice cream
yeah I love it I [__] hate it
because I'm just like can I just have
like a real dessert can I have something
that isn't fruit like I I don't want
fruit tastes so good here right now it's
fine I just I just preferred an ice
cream on a Tiramisu or something you're
not even obsessed with like other than
strawberries do you guys ever get those
frozen mango chunks from 7-Eleven oh
yeah yeah yeah they're so cool
killing like two bags at night
it's like it's like it's like having a
little sorbet between your fingertips
those are really good it's so cool I was
at first I was kind of sauce about it
because I'm like oh that's a really
cheap for a bag of rice because usually
you know when you get actual mangoes in
Japan they're like cost twenty thousand
[__] yeah yeah so when I saw like how
much are they like 200 candles they're
like 200 yen 200 yen for a frozen bag of
mangoes like decent size like that and
I'm like all right I'll give it a go and
I had it so it's so good so good in the
summer banging I do like bananas I just
realized that I like breakfast but I
wouldn't have it as dessert
not even like a banana bread like a
banana split the [__] no that shit's
awful what
wait so you don't like any fruits but
bananas basically no I do like fruits I
just there's never an occasion where I
would want a fruit over a vegetable I
don't know why I'm just like even in any
situation yeah I think I just always
prefer vegetables what if it's a really
hot day vegetables and what if you
wanted a smoothie
ones I'll get the ones where they put
all the green [__] in it because it
tastes good
I mean I get that but sometimes you it's
a hot day and you're like yeah I could
go for like a mango smoothie or like a
hot tea
no I remember in Thailand everybody was
like yo let's go to the store get a
mango smoothie get like a watermelon
smoothie yeah
Connor being the [__] British person
he's just like do you have hot tea
it's like 30 degrees
unfortunately kind of didn't realize
that 99 of drinks in Thailand come with
like a bucket full of ice no matter
where you go oh yeah they they gave me I
had this um I tried uh Thai tea yeah
[__] hell this is sweet yeah oh yeah
can you do it without the sugar I asked
that on the plane I was like can I have
a tea without sugar and she was like
yeah it doesn't have sugar in it I'm
like no no this one's super sweet can I
have one that isn't sweet no it just
comes with sugar she was like what
that's not that's just tea yeah
like I want this tea this tea you've
given me but way less sweet it's like
calm me down
I was like I know it I know you have it
I know you have it give it to me have
you ever had like Southern sweet tea
yeah yeah it's awful that shit's [__]
gross yeah it is it is of course you
like that no I don't no no no I don't
like it when it's super sweet but I went
to Alabama once and I had some of the
best peach iced tea I've ever had in my
life yeah it might it might be good if
you put enough sugar in it
the first time I had it was in uh in
Atlanta and I tried it because my friend
was like yo you should try this it's
it's you know it's Southern tea and I'm
like okay let's let's see how it is bro
it was like sugar water yeah yeah
literally it is sugar water it's yeah we
make it uh to make it palatable right
because tea is hard to drink if you're
not generationally pressured into it I
mean not every culture gets tea well
what state did we do a show at that they
voted like the top thing America does
best and they voted like tea and oh yeah
some of them some of them thought they
did tea better than anywhere else yeah
that was insulting where was this oh oh
it was uh it's one of the Southern
States oh that makes sense no I don't
think it was I think it was like was it
not it was a state that they threw all
the tea into the ocean what state was
that oh Boston Boston yeah Massachusetts
yeah I think it was Massachusetts right
Boston's in Massachusetts right yeah
yeah yeah yeah
they're like we do tea better than
anyone else I'm like oh really
I do remember that yes
I'm really hoping you guys were trolling
yeah so okay what okay what do you hate
about lamb what what do you hate about
laughs
Australian I was so offended
right now a lot of people didn't like
that I basically I heard that you didn't
like lemon my response was let's try
every language why did they not like
that I think because they were like
that's how you pressure someone into
hating something more and I was like no
no no I I went into with an open mind
yeah yeah no I don't agree with that
stuff but but the the thing that you
said that I don't mind if you don't like
lamb I am offended but yeah okay it
tastes Dusty yeah the thing that you
said that that made me think like huh
was that you said it tastes like goat's
cheese no Dinah said that I didn't say
that diet
okay it tastes I can't Emily explain it
Emily no I actually kind of agree with
you no yeah I've been I've been holding
this in
because
for the longest are allowed back in
Australia
for the longest time I was like I kind
of like didn't like lamb uh as well just
because it has this like really weird
aftertaste yeah it gets me yeah and is
it like the gaminess of it it's the
dustiness
you gotta get that checked out and like
the goat's cheese thing it's uh I I the
the reason I was put off by goat's shoes
is because it did have this aftertaste
and it kind of reminded me of the Lamb
after taste but like even stronger so I
kind of get what Titus is talking about
um ghost cheese also taste Dusty what
the [__] I love this
I mean ghost stories isn't my favorite
but Dusty is not the worst
I can't I just it's such a bizarre
flavor I can't describe the action I
know a lot of people who don't like lamb
saying that like it tastes very like
earthy or like um very gamey is the word
you know that they use where like it
smells like a wild animal yeah I I just
like when people eat deer feel the same
way it is good it is good yeah it
doesn't have that same I've never had
Bears so I don't know like how gamey
that is I noticed when we were eating
meat it was like the closer it tasted to
a meat you recognized you were like this
is good
tastes I think deer tastes closer to
beef than it does oh definitely yeah
yeah yeah I think it does okay but here
is considered more gameier than lamb
well here's the thing I used to like
really really hate loud because I'd
already get like really cheap Cuts right
and then once I started getting like
proper like you know America like
Australian lamb chops and stuff like
that I was like oh this actually slaps
pretty hard yeah so I'm sorry what
you're from the UK what are you talking
about why are you picking up their land
we have we have some of the best no
questions actually actually I think it's
UK that put me off land for the longest
time because I think I think
I think the aftertaste in the UK lamb is
just wait all at least the ones I had in
fact you'll learn from
wow look anytime we'd have lamb at like
any roasts like dinners or like any it
was mostly like school lunches that put
me off lamb because it was like
obviously it wasn't good cuts of lamb
because they were [__] school dinner
school lunches again it's very abundant
yeah we had a lot there's more sheep in
Wales than people oh that's true yeah so
I'd had it a lot in like school
um and I just hated this weird
aftertaste every time I didn't get lamb
in school though did you not no what the
[__]
lamb is mad expensive in Australia do
they barely gave us pasta
sometimes you'd have like you know there
was a special occasion where they'd have
like a kind of like roast they would
like the cheapest kind of interesting
I'm like damn they gave you food
wow yeah I mean it wasn't good cuts of
lamb obviously because at to me it
tastes like [__] put me offline for the
longest time only got into lamb actually
when you had the good lamp yeah when I
had the good lamp probably like in my
span of moving to Japan actually because
I've just avoided lamb for my entire
life but it's still if it's like a cheap
cut of lamb a lot of the times I just I
just can't handle it so so you like the
expensive lamb now like you like Lambs
or only if it's the good cut yes okay I
mean that's me with steak like if it's a
good cut of steak then I like it but I
was kind of the same with you like I
grew up eating a lot of like really
cheap cuts of like beef steak so it's
like it kind of pulled me off for the
longest time and then when I've moved to
Japan I had a really good cut of steak
and I'm like oh steak can be good wow
that's surprising what are you talking
about the Australian steak is still good
though Joey yeah but like you can also
get like it's it's like lamb in the UK
where it's like it's very abundant like
you can get the really cheap Cuts but
you can also get the really expensive
cuts okay I guess the ones I ate my
whole life were just like mostly the
really cheap Cuts because I didn't have
any money growing up so it's like yeah
oh this is not that great yeah because
it's kind of took you to Genghis Khan to
in Hokkaido right what was your
impression of that
I would not go again but I am glad I can
finally like put it to rest I just don't
like lamb what do you mean you don't
like lamb tongue huh
no I'm not a fan of tongue in general I
think I don't like the texture it's too
chewy it's too don't like don't like
British lamb don't like [__] time
wait what's it wait what's your favorite
cut of the Yakiniku
my favorite cuts
um if you don't like tongue
anything anything but just hung like I I
[__] love like 90 of cuts except for
the tongue okay question question okay
you go to Yakitori right okay what's
your go-to you order you can order one
stick from a Yakitori place what are you
ordering oh negative 100 yeah me too
what do you got I don't really like
yakitoris
[Laughter]
is this scripted is this a troll
but there'll be a video out on your
Channel at some point where we'll be
going over all this stuff yeah more
detail oh my God okay